if we're the if we're the one that that
is being loved by somebody else then
we feel like we have to measure up to
them
in this case you can think about like
you know parents and and children but he
actually says parents
you know that that sort of dynamic is
not as strong as the loved
lover Dynamic when somebody actually
loves us in a romantic way
we're sort of on our toes we don't want
to disappoint them and what if we're
infatuated with somebody else we really
don't want to disappoint them we want to
appear to be the best person that we are
and you know this can lead you into a
lot of problems can it because if you
act too differently from the person who
you really are now you've got this
appearance that you've got to keep up
all the time when you're with this
person and if things work out you're
going to be with this person an awful
lot of time aren't you